hi guys I'm Lucy and welcome to copy
editing TV your daily reminder to double
check your spelling and grammar
especially if you work in the video game
industry you see we're preparing
ourselves for driveclub but there's
something that's not quite right no I'm
not talking about that hashtag that they
try to make happen it's something even
worse there is an error on it box art
society has published a picture of the
back of drive from Fox there's the usual
list of what the game can offer some
pretty pictures of cars and all the
regular stuff but then there's a curious
line that says raced in hundreds of
online and offline players wait what it
was probably meant to say that you can
race in hundreds of online and offline
races but who knows maybe driveclub
features a mode where you can inhabit
the bodies of both online and offline
players well probably not oh well it
could be worse at least it's not as bad
as misspelling the actual name of the
game we all remember what happened with
resident evil revelations on 3d yet in
that particular instance Capcom offered
owners of the game replacement covers
given that this is a smaller mistake
we're not sure if Sony's gonna do the
same so what do you make riddles are you
looking forward to racing in your online
and offline players let me know in the
comments to see what we thought a first
time drive club make sure to check out
our hashtag review over at hashtag
gamespot com